Bridge have been involved in a very  different kind of delivery William I  know ACC flights got a few ships lined  up for you when you can get back to us  but in the meantime on behalf of  everybody on the search and rescue force  would like to congratulate you both on  the safe arrival of your new son  absolutely fantastic news with thrilled  both of you William Duchess  congratulations on the birth of your  baby boy William hope you enjoy your  placenta leaf and we'll see you on ship  see on behalf of the IDF Mountain Rescue  Service headquarters and indeed the  other ally of motrin rescue service  teams here in the 70th anniversary with  it congratulate photo credit wales and  the duchess of cambridge on the birth of  their son  Oh